like there's only one thing that annoys
me more
about getting woken up just just to eat
you know on a plane which i wasn't even
hungry in the first place
and that is babies on a plane i don't
know
man crying babies on a plane just
triggers something in me man i think it
should be legally allowed cancelling
headphones
i don't they're a lifesaver literally
the what are they called
dude i i feel like i feel like a baby's
cry
pierces any kind of anything dude those
sony
wx fourth out whatever the [ __ ] they are
the stupidest name they've ever picked
for them
those amazing noise-counting headphones
you won't hear a [ __ ] thing
yeah yeah cause i've i i don't know i
don't
i don't usually use noise-cancelling
headphones that might be my problem
because right now i'm just like i think
it should be legally allowed to punch
babies if they cry on a plane like
that's
can we can we all just like i feel like
they might cry morgan
i don't know how the parents and how the
parents would feel about this
gonna hit him just right like mad max
when the baby starts crying apparently
but like i mean all right ma'am problem
solved i never thought i never thought i
needed
[Music]
austin powell's junior chopper
oh my god i never thought i needed
noise-canceling headphones until i had
them and then i can't i literally go
everywhere with them
like you you see me i'm always where you
were yeah i do not go anywhere without
my noise-canceling headphones now
i would only use noise-cancelling
headphones for the airplane that's
because
that's what you think okay what in what
other like situations it's so nice on
the train
or any form of transport walking around
just getting uh isolated and hearing
your music and just the music
and if you want you can hear some
background noise it doesn't really
matter it's like living through an amv
it's fun it's great i want to hear
philip defranco when i'm walking
downtown going what's up beautiful
bastards in my ear
right in my it's like right in my ear
all i want to hear is fill in my i don't
know i feel like i
zone out enough as it is i don't need
noise-cancelling headphones like
i literally just walk in front of a
truck or something i've had noise cancer
you kind of you learn to adapt you
become more weary
i look around a lot more now yeah this
is a good thing
i'm like daredevil right like you you
take out one sense so you gotta
compensate for it with your other sense
or something just buy them you'll see
you'll see
them yeah they're great because i always
thought like expensive headphones like i
don't need more than 20 bucks or 50
bucks headphones what a scam and then i
bought them and i'm like i'm such a fool
i was so wrong the whole time the beeps
and boobs sound even better now oh they
are amazing
yeah i mean i changed everything i did
used to have like really really good
headphones but they were just
real happy they were just like a real
hassle to uh just
lug around well i stopped using them
that's right mine are like you they fall
in themselves pretty easy to put a coat
pocket or something i just use the
airpods yeah that's why that's why i'm
i like i like using like you know
earbuds
whenever it's daily life if it's on a
plane yeah i'll
bring the headphones yeah i wear the
headphones everywhere
see like especially this time like i
don't mind the headphones either but
like
this time of year when it gets hot as
[ __ ] yeah
i hate having headphones around i need
something to distract me from the heat
so just blasting the audio add more heat
take one of the senses away from me so i
can just go to another world so i don't
[ __ ] pay attention to japan anymore
no i hate that because i start sweating
here like on my ears and then when i
take it off it's like
well you have a lot of hair though so
that might be why because i don't really
have like that much hair around here so
what i mean that's pretty nice you're
like muffling all the hair in there
you're like [ __ ] making it
like [ __ ] like raise it up like this
to like hear anything
be fine then yeah you're good yeah you
two are fine yeah you'll be fine
i'll be good i'll be good soon enough
i'll have no hair and then i'll be no
problem
then you'll just have like a sunburn
marker